en france confirmation d'une reprise
épidémique et prolongation du pass and i
ter jusqu'à l'été c'est dans ce contexte
qu emmanuel macron prendra la parole
mardi soir peut-être pour annoncer de
nouvelles mesures restrictives le fameux
pass qui fait comme un fax à mener le
biais de manifestations à paris à l'une
des mobilisations ont été organisées par
le leader des patriotes florian
philippot et dans le cortège d'entre eux
reporter également rozic on trouve à
tout de suite
bonjour avec des mains alors quelle est
l'ambiance dans le cortège
[Musique]
écoutez amiral ambiance est parfaitement
calme les on entend les slogans
maintenant que l'on connaît très bien
dans ces cortèges de florian philippot
liberté on a même chanté la marseillaise
on est en arrivant ici place pierre
laroque dans le 7e arrondissement juste
à côté du ministère de la santé
l'endroit n'est évidemment pas anodin
alors il y avait plusieurs
manifestations prévues aujourd'hui
savent où je me trouve actuellement donc
vous l'avez dit le défilé des patriotes
emmené par heure florian philippot l'une
des figures politiques de l'opposition à
ce fameux me passe sanitaire mais
également d'autres rassemblements des
gilets jaunes mais pas seulement et ici
dans la capitale et dans tout l'hexagone
alors une journée un samedi de
mobilisation qui ne qui doit bien sûr à
l'actualité législative puisque vous
l'avez dit hier l'assemblée le projet de
loi dit de vigilance sanitaire a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale qui a
finalement eu le dernier mot on s'y
attendait un petit peu alors selon me
cependant la l'heure n'est pas à la
résignation si l'on en croit florian
philippon écouter
or rien ne savait plus où tu es des
peuples se sont libérés après des années
de persévérance et il était tout le
temps tout le temps tout temps là chaque
semaine macron va parler
mardi soir je pense que s'il parle c'est
qu'il se sent que le doute est en train
de s'immiscer dans les esprits au
contraire les ça n'est pas ça ne passe
plus comme une lettre à la poste je
l'avais vu au parlement c'est plus le
mois juillet août ou passer facilement à
une large majorité le sénat la sonde et
là ça a été beaucoup plus compliquée ça
a été hier plus de débattre parce que le
doute s'est immiscé dans les esprits
avec le freezer guette le débat qui
monte sur les effets secondaires la
question du pas saint hilaire de la
troisième dose l'état de l'hôpital ce
qui a été révélé sur les ligues son père
mais tout ça est en train de créer un
espèce de doute de controverse et sa
macro le sens il veut réessayer de
reprendre la main du narratif
alors je vous rappelle amira les
principales dispositions de ce projet de
loi donc l'état transitoire de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire prolongé donc
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 et avec lui et
bien la possibilité de recourir à ce
fameux pass sanitaires les sanctions ont
été revues à la hausse pour les
fraudeurs qu'encore une fois ce pas
solitaire et plus de nouveautés les
directeurs des écoles ainsi que les
chefs d'établissements des collèges et
des lycées pourront désormais avoir
accès au statut vaccinal des élèves tout
ceci est bien sans contrôle du parlement
au moins jusqu'à l'été jusqu'à la moitié
de l'été 2022 et c'est bien ce qui a
motivé ces manifestants a défilé
aujourd'hui dans ce cortège mais dans
tout l'hexagone
merci gamins pour toutes ces précisions